what does buson mean that should be easy
busing like
uh okay like what's your name and how
old are you I am Jenna I'm 31 31 I know
I know the shoes are nice they're like
slipons they're zipup oh they kind of
look like yours yeah kind of if you
squint and look at it from my way what's
your favorite Starbucks drink ooh
Starbucks probably like an almond
Lotte okay how many followers do you
have on Instagram
like 1,800 maybe or
something why should we think that
you're cool I like teach kids dance so I
feel like can you show us a Tik Tok
dance drop a beat or
something oh I used to be able to do
that subtle break dance that was
cool two watch just be all cool bro oh
wait oh oh okay I'll take it why did
that happen because you're kind of
trying too hard okay a little bit like
if you kind are you saying that cuz
she's in her 30s I mean the dance moves
those are cool but some of it I kind of
get where she's coming from